[Music]
starting today
visitors to rome's famed coliseum can
walk in the footsteps of ancient
gladiators after a massive restoration
the area below the main stage is opening
to the public
in ancient times it held workers
fighters and exotic animals
and our chris chris livesay joins us
from
deep down in the coliseum with how
visitors can step back
into history chris lucky assignment good
morning to you
good morning tony yes from the deepest
depths of the coliseum now
just imagine it above me 75 000 ancient
romans
screaming for blood but not a single one
of those spectators
ever got to see the colosseum from down
here
as a theater in the round the coliseum
had no backstage
instead as russell crowe's character and
gladiator found out the hard way
it had an understatement
you can imagine you know how astonishing
it would could be for public and also
for the animal
like a jack in the box
and now the coliseum is allowing
visitors inside
the deepest depths of this layer known
as the hyper gm
and it's been a while it hasn't raised
the curtain since the year 523
says technical director barbara nacero
more or less
1 800 people could work
here in the backstage so just
imagine to keep a live hyper there were
hippos here
yes of course you can still see the
small arches that hoisted
the greatest special effects the world
had ever seen
it was a very very beautiful show
but a very bloody show too no everything
was bloody
and not just for gladiators even
convicts were forced to perform
classical theater then eaten alive by
wild animals when the scene called for
it this is
a marvelous work of architecture
but it's also the monument of our
civilization how we are changed
now accessible like never before thanks
to the latest
phase of a 30 million dollar restoration
the owner of italian luxury shoe company
todds
now this is beautiful what is this see
it was
our first factory my grandfather factory
so from this to all this
to the coliseum this is italy
it's not only when you see a bags
when you see a pair of expensive shoes
is an aptitude for the italian people
such a colossal restoration he says
shows italians today can still
accomplish great things
now some great news for travelers this
week italy announced it's
lifting the ban on americans so long as
they've been vaccinated
tested negative or can prove they've had
covid
check one of those boxes and you too can
see the coliseum
like a gladiator jerica chris lives say
in rome
thank you can't wait to go i i've been
it's amazing you don't want to go like a
gladiator
no no they didn't end well for the
gladiators we'll be right back